wo ist dein leben selber
wer nichts zu sehen geht es gut danke
jetzt gut ich bin auf dem weg zu meinem
praktikum und du ja ich zeige mich jetzt
mit einer freundin zum frühstück ich hab
keine lust auf dieses kein team das in
harmonie und wie gefällt dir das
praktikum die arbeitsbedingungen der
firma sind toll obwohl die arbeitszeiten
an manchen tagen ziemlich lang sind und
den chef ist ja nett ist streng aber
hilfsbereit und verständnisvoll und ich
finde es gut dass sich viele
verantwortungsvolle aufgaben haben cool
das klingt super ich hoffe dass deine
kollegen auch nett und unkompliziert
sind ja aber ich habe mit den meisten
nicht viel zu tun
ich arbeite nicht so viel im team ich
finde ich ein bisschen schade aber wir
treffen uns jeden mittag zum essen
na ja es kann ja nicht gleich am anfang
alles perfekt sein nico geht eigentlich
ganz gut er ist immer noch auf der suche
nach einem ausbildungsplatz solchen von
dir grüßen
ok dann wünsche ich dir viel spaß auf
der arbeit